ahora les voy a mostrar lo que yo creo
que son probablemente las dos derivadas
más interesantes de todo el cálculo
bueno me voy a reservar eso no se me
ocurre ninguna otra en este momento pero
estas son definitivamente para mí las
más claras averigüemos cuál es la
derivada del logaritmo natural y solo
para repasar vamos a checar bueno el
logaritmo natural de cualquier cosa es
lo mismo que el logaritmo base de de esa
cosa eso es solo un repaso entonces
derivamos esto
la derivada bueno creo que voy a
necesitar un poco de espacio para
realizar esto entonces la derivada del
logaritmo natural de x es igual y vamos
a hacer uso a la definición de lo que es
la derivada vamos a tomar la pendiente
de la recta tangente a la función en
dicho punto y vamos a ir haciendo que
los puntos se vayan aproximando es decir
el límite cuando delta x se aproxima a 0
de la función evaluada en x + delta x
menos la función evaluada en x todo eso
sobre delta x en este caso nuestra
función de la que estamos hablando es el
logaritmo natural por lo que queda el
logaritmo natural de x + delta x de x +
delta x menos el logaritmo natural
evaluado en x y todo eso sobre delta x
ahora si recuerdan los otros vídeos de
las derivadas esto es la pendiente y
solo estamos hallando
cuando los puntos se van aproximando
cada vez más es decir cuando delta x
tiende a cero veamos si podemos realizar
algunas de las propiedades del logaritmo
para simplificar lo espero lo recuerdes
y si no revisa las propiedades del
logaritmo que está en otros vídeos por
ejemplo logaritmo de a menos logaritmo
de b
eso es igual al logaritmo de a entre b y
eso sale del hecho de que el logaritmo
son esencialmente exponentes y siguen
las reglas de la función exponencial si
esto no tiene sentido para ti debería
revisarlo ahora utilicemos esto para la
ecuación déjenme reescribir todo
cambiando de colores para evitar que se
vuelva monótono así que tenemos el
límite cuando delta x se aproxima a 0 de
esa gran cosa y si el logaritmo de a
menos el logaritmo de b es igual a
logaritmo de a entre b eso lo usamos en
el numerador de este lado así que
tenemos logaritmo natural de x + delta x
/ x / x y todo eso ya que hemos
utilizado esta propiedad va a ir sobre
delta x
esto equivale al límite cuando delta x
se aproxima a 0 y este es un muy buen
momento para cambiar de colores delta x
se aproxima a 0 b y ahora déjenme
colocar este delta x del denominador
afuera así que esto es 1 entre delta x
todo eso del logaritmo natural de x / x
que es uno más
delta x entre x
entre ellos
y esto es el límite de todo esto ahora
voy a utilizar otra propiedad del
logaritmo y con suerte tú también lo vas
a recordar déjenme colocar de este lado
las propiedades que no son parte de la
demostración entonces a logaritmo de b
es lo mismo que el logaritmo de b
elevado a la y eso viene de cuando tomas
algo a un exponente y luego a otro
exponente solo hay que multiplicar
dichos exponentes
no quiero confundirte espero que lo
recuerdes ahora como lo aplicamos acá
esto es de la forma a logaritmo natural
de b así que esta expresión será la
misma que el límite y déjenme ahora
cambiar de colores nuevamente esto es lo
mismo que el límite cuando delta x se
aproxima a cero del logaritmo natural
y logaritmo natural
de uno más
delta x entre x
y esto esto es elevado a la 1 entre
delta x utilizando dicha propiedad
ahora todo esto es el logaritmo natural
de ello y luego vamos a aplicar el
límite si has visto los problemas de
interés compuesto y sabes la definición
de creo que te va a resultar familiar
pero permíteme hacer una sustitución que
debería hacer esto más visible hagamos
la sustitución vamos a llamarlo vamos a
llamarlo n no no no no no n no mejor y
va a ser igual a delta x sobre x
y luego si eso es correcto podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por equis y
obtener que x es igual a delta equis o
también 1 entre delta equis es igual a 1
sobre x
todo esto es equivalente hagamos ahora
la sustitución así que si vamos a tomar
el límite cuando delta x se aproxima a 0
en esta expresión si delta x se aproxima
x a que se aproxima o pues a 0 por lo
que delta x aproximándose a 0 es lo
mismo que hubo aproximándose a 0
así que podemos escribirlo como el
límite cuando u se aproxima a cero o se
aproxima a cero del logaritmo natural de
uno más
delta x entre equis que es u
que su elevado a la 1 entre delta x que
es 1 / x sub
recordemos que estamos obteniendo el
logaritmo natural de todo esto
también hay que recordar una propiedad
de las potencias la cual vamos a pintar
de un color diferente sabemos que al abc
es lo mismo que a la vez elevado al ac
vamos a dejar esto de ese lado por
separado
y eso nos da que el límite
el límite cuando uno se aproxima a cero
el logaritmo natural de de uno más
a la 1 entre v porque este es un 1 entre
x sub cierto y 1 entre v todo eso
elevado a la 1 entre x como lo obtuve de
esta propiedad que anunciamos hace un
momento que viene de que 1 entre 1 x 1 /
x es uno entre x sub
ahora bien podemos usar la propiedad
morada del logaritmo si yo tengo vea la
puedo sacar la a hacia afuera ahora
tomamos este 1 entre x el logaritmo
natural y ahora que tenemos ya casi
estamos al final tenemos el límite
cuando uno se aproxima a cero
y este 1 / x lo colocamos afuera del
logaritmo natural 1 / x logaritmo
natural de uno más a la 1 entre v
parece bien cuando estamos calculando el
límite este término 1 entre x no se
involucra para nada por lo cual
podríamos sacarlo del límite no le
afecta a este término y ahora estamos
esencialmente diciendo lo que le sucede
a esta expresión a la expresión cuando
el límite de útil de a 0 esto es
equivalente a 1 entre x
el logaritmo natural
del límite aquí es cuando metemos el
límite del límite cuando tiende a cero
de uno más uno a la 1 entre v
y ahora con suerte reconocerás que esta
es la definición del número b esto
quizás lo recuerdes de los vídeos de
interés compuesto o tal vez lo recuerdes
como el límite cuando n se aproxima a
infinito de uno más uno entre n a la n
por estas dos son equivalentes solo
basta con que hagas o igual a uno entre
n y obtendrías esta fórmula entonces
esta expresión de acá es el número en el
mismo número
nos estamos ya acercando al final
todo esto es equivalente a 1 / x
el logaritmo natural y esto que ya
sabemos que es el número de una de las
formas de obtener el número de es el
logaritmo natural de y cuál es un
logaritmo natural bueno es el logaritmo
en base es decir 1 entre x logaritmo
base d es decir a qué exponente hay que
elevar para que nos dé bueno pues eso es
1 cierto entonces nos queda uno entre x
por 1 que es 1 entre ellos y ya está la
derivada del logaritmo natural de x es
igual a 1 entre x que después de lo que
ya hemos hecho debería quedar mucho más
claro que la derivada del logaritmo
natural de x es x a la menos 11 entre x
fascinante